it was the week before Christmas in all
around town bball fans were dying to
watch LeBron Steph and Russell's row now
bring back the short shorts who wears
short shorts I do I wear shorts a
basketball miracle right here on
Christmas Day stuff to do our stockings
by the Jolly NBA join us for games who
win something else cool in between all
the dunks a sneak peek of Deadpool I
hope you've been nice see you on
Christmas boys and girls who are you
talking to hmm oh that's good
hi dad Poole here with an important
public service announcement this is your
brain actually it's a chimichanga but
I'm making a point because this is your
brain on IMAX bigger is better right
hey youtubers is Charlie happy 12 days
of Deadpool so this new teaser is all
about him just dropping poo on people's
doorsteps hanging out with weasel
dropping NBA teasers if you guys didn't
know so like let's do a quick breakdown
of that this is mostly gonna be Deadpool
funny moments but like the really
important information is that even even
if you don't watch ESPN there's a new
Deadpool trailer like a full trailer
coming Christmas Day it's gonna come
pretty much in the middle of the day
like in the middle of the NBA game you
might be asking yourself why are they
dropping it in the middle of the NBA
game it's really just an eyeball thing
like they want everybody that doesn't
normally watch Deadpool content to see
it so they're just shoving it in front
of as many eyeballs as possible they did
the same thing with one of the Star Wars
trailers do not worry I will totally do
a video for it comes I mean if you're
subscribed you will totally see it in
your feed and important stuff more
Deadpool funny moments so enjoy this
montage and remember why Deadpool is one
of the best comic book characters
[Music]
so important stuff there is a Deadpool
teaser coming tomorrow and then there's
gonna be a full trailer coming on
Christmas Day so a whole bunch of
Deadpool stuff this week in between Star
Wars videos I'll be doing a lot more
Star Wars in the next couple of days too
while you guys wait for all that stuff
to post you can click here for all my
Star Wars Episode 7 videos and you can
click here for all my Deadpool videos
thank you so much watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you